et voilà comme ça je crois que ça
tiendra restants pensent jury souffrance
ah tiens vous êtes la cera canton de
vous voir c'est un grand jour
aujourd'hui dans l'île aux enfants c'est
la fête de tous les pays
voyez tous ces drapeaux ce sont les
enfants de l'île qui les ont pas est ce
que vous savez ce qui représente comme
pays
je les tue et on va faire un jeu afin de
reconnaître oui d'accord mais si vous
êtes d'accord
les enfants et les voir venez vite avec
julie revenez nous voir will la regarder
ces drapeaux et sauf
est ce que vous les reconnaissez on
commence par le premier celui là celui
là c'est la france celui là la turquie
non c'est l'urss
celui ci a laissé espagne celui là celui
là c'est l'italie très bien et celui ci
là c'est la belgique
venez voir les autres rené avec moi
alors je voulais vivre cela je les dis
ça c'est la grande bretagne et ça c'est
l'algérie l'algérie très bien si vous
les connaissez vous me le dites on
entend ça portugal il les connaît tous
israël israël l'egypte la suisse
les etats unis d'amérique et la nine
fédéral très bien très bien avait été
formidable
am je suis content je suis vraiment très
content impact à la tim cup
casimir a bien dit aujourd'hui je sais
la racontant il dans une telle forme
très content et très fier de moi
casini qu'elle unit c'est à cause de la
fête de tous les pays que tu es sig est
aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est pour ça et
pourquoi es tu si gay parce que le
comité d'organisation de la fête m'a
confié une mission importante ou là à
toi hoyé alors eh bien non c'est une
petite question comme ça et et qu'est-ce
que de charger tout et bien voilà il y
as sur la grand place et des mâts avec
des drapeaux
chaque fois que la fanfare jouera un
hymne national je devrai hissé le
drapeau correspondant peut-être très
fort un bris mais surtout surtout il
faut connaître tous les hymnes nationaux
casimir tu les connais quoi ah oui non
je n'avais pas pensé il n'avait pas
pensé à ça dont je ne connais pas enfin
casimir commandes eu à faire quand il
faudra hisser le drapeau
oh là là tu sera complètement perdu
j'entends tenir
je crois que j'ai une idée venez on va
voir julie avec son catalogue sonore ça
va nous sauver
rabon julie oui je lui dis moi tu as
toujours son boxeur à taratata
je crois que les fuyait c'est idiot on
va s'en sortir avec les tue la
formidable dit long est-ce que tu as
tous les hymnes nationaux
oui bien sûr parfait alors est ce qu'il
va se passer kazimiya et puis vous les
enfants vous m'écoutez 1 et vous touche
chez vous julie va nous envoyer des
hymnes nationaux et à chaque fois
eh bien vous montrerez un drapeau qui
correspond c'est compris tout le monde a
compris tout c'est simple c'est julie
vas-y envoie le premier est bien
non abbas a enfin répété bien sa musique
et chants aux ennemis la grande bretagne
mais coûte jusqu'au bout tu as trouvé
c'est parfait et le drapeau montré le
mois chercher en écoutant la fin voilà
c'est très bien gelli l autre registre m
[Musique]
chercher en même temps cherché cherché
aller à droite à gauche ont regardé les
drapeaux
[Musique]
sinon c'est terminé je les suivais mois
suivez moi à mon avis il est par ici
celui-ci nos c'était l'urss
julie s'appelait voici
[Musique]
notez bien
les allées chercher
cherchez les c'est là où je suis là
[Musique]
moi j'ai pas trouvé sa voie c'est ça les
états unis d'amérique
c'était celui ci julie continue bien
cherché
les émirs huawei attend c'est par là on
chauffe c'est celui ci disait il a
laissé très bien tu as est tombé kazemi
a dirigé du tout les mêmes
julie un autre regardez à droite à
gauche
rené voir paris ses mémoires paris seuil
et c'est par là cherchez vous séchez vos
là-bas alors c'est lequel
c'est l'espagne très bien bravo vous
aviez trouvé mou c'est formidable julie
alors s'il te plaît samedi quelque chose
ressenti
évidemment évidemment c'est la france
merci julie cassé il en casimir
ouais tout ce qu'on a fait ensemble
c'est un bien t'aider
quand il faudra hisser les couleurs au
débat mais non pas du tout comment pas
du tout parce que c'est pas la peine il
y à quoi un numéro sur chaque main alors
drapeau un hapoël drapeau gay drapeaux
des drapeaux trois apôtres warrap au
capot quatre drapeaux cinq ans c'était
possible